now let's do this let's jump jump over
to our good friends in australia and let
me clap back at uh the australian i mean
it's getting wild
so uh australia
is in the process of building more camps
which they already have several of these
are camps with relocatable cabins they
say for quarantining people who are as
they say when they're coming from abroad
they need to be placed into this camp
into a bungalow to be kept safe
so that they can't infect people with
covet oh be protected
and they have to wait there now i
referred to this as a concentration camp
why
because the word concentration camp
doesn't literally mean nazi death camp
right and
there is some um
you know you you are trying to evoke an
emotion by saying concentration camp i
did not choose those words lightly i'm
literally trying to point out what's
happening the government of australia
has built camps
they are putting people in those camps
they are claiming it's for safety this
is step one in the 100 step process
towards locking up people sealing them
in and then letting them die
will it get to that point maybe not no
idea but when has the government built
camps with real relocatable cabins for
people deemed suspected of having a
sickness to be to be locked away for a
short period of time when has that
turned out well i want to just clarify
you're exactly right on the definition
of concentration camp it's a camp where
large numbers of persons such as
whatever political prisoners whatever
are detained for the purposes of
concentrating them in one place exactly
that's what that means the death camps
were a very specific type of
concentration camp not common right and
so
you're trying to evoke an emotion by
calling it a concentration camp
obviously sure of course yeah but quite
literally it's just when people are
concentrated in one place which is what
they're doing
now
i will i will uh as much as i typically
don't like doing this i'm gonna actually
just
call out quillette and claire lemon
specifically because i used to be a big
fan and now i think they are one of the
most they're one of the perfect examples
quillette and claire of how you get the
nazis
so you look at nazi germany and people
would say like how did it get so bad no
it's really simple when the people who
are claiming to be the intelligent
dissidents started apologizing for the
actions of the nazis any reasonable
dissent was gone and it's probably
because they were scared of the state
they were scared of being included in as
an undesirable or as unclean or being
labeled they were scared
recently we've seen with the opposition
to critical race applied principles in
schools claire lehman of quillette kathy
newman james lindsey meaning she takes
things he says greatly out of context to
try and smear him which is really weird
because why would you do that he's
talking about american political issues
and there's no reason to take what he's
saying out of context
recently when i tweeted concentration
camp in response to the camps they're
building in australia claire did a tweet
saying that i called them death camps
which is again out of context or just
hyperbolic and then criticized me which
ended up now in the australian as i'm
told one of murdock's australian papers
now in this
article
she says mocked we may be but compare
the death rates
this is claire lehman coilette
supposedly supposed to be classically
liberal challenging the wokeness the
establishment defending the
authoritarian practices of australia a
video of a man being taken out of a
hotel because there was a manhunt
because he didn't quarantine and he was
seen sneezing in an elevator there's a
video and we have it of a guy who they
they show up to his house with the
police in full gear and he's confused
it's what's happening they said he's
being taken to a hotel quarantine
indefinitely
news nine australia is saying this
when you have police younger people's
homes and saying we're gonna quarantine
you
then they say we are building we've
built camps and we will build more camps
at what point do you say i kind of don't
trust the government doing this
do you think that when the nazis started
building these camps they went out and
told the public what their intention was
no of course not well i mean the
presumption is if you believe the
stories that we read uh when the 101st
airborne first came upon one of these
camps that was the first that anybody
except for the people that lived nearby
that saw the ashes of bodies burning
going by their homes like those people
in the villages knew but then like
people in munich they had no idea
allegedly anyways right well so the
propaganda is you can look back at it
one of the uh the famous bits of
propaganda from the nazis was that the
warsaw ghetto for instance the jews
carried typhus
and for the sake of the health you know
we needed to get in there and we need to
do something about it that's what they
were doing
so they they pull up in the trucks they
say get on the train cart and then when
i see a video of a guy with the cops
showing up and they're like it's time
for your indefinite quarantine and he's
like all right mate i'm like that guy
did not learn a single thing from
history now i'll admit it's a big
challenge what do you do when
multiple cops show up quarantined ready
to take you in it's like man
i'm not going to presume to be the
arbiter of morality on this one to tell
you what you should or shouldn't do but
i will say it's shocking for us
nonetheless to watch a video out of
australia where a guy says he apparently
let me let me jump to this uh this tweet
um now i will admit first and foremost
there's video it says news9 exclusive
nothing comes up people have been
searching for this guy's name because
like the search algorithms show you
people are searching for this guy's name
but nothing comes up from news9 and i
don't know the original source on this
video but this man says you can see him
the cops show up to his house they're
wearing gear
he says he got a covid test just for
peace of mind never got alerted to what
happened until one day the cops showed
up saying he was positive and would be
taken in for an indefinite quarantine i
don't know what happened to this guy or
where he's ended up but why would anyone
look at that and say that's fine that's
normal now to throw it back to colette
what they what what happened so what uh
cleliman has written for the australian
she briefly mentions me saying in the
opening paragraph the international
media spotlight has been shining on
australia lately and not in a good way
last week the left-leaning atlantic
magazine published an article that asked
rhetorically if we were still a liberal
democracy no australia is not you uh
that's me adding that in she goes on to
say ustv host tucker carlson told his
audience of three million viewers
australia has descended into
totalitarianism which it has and on
social media popular us youtube
personality tim poole likened our
quarantined facilities to concentration
camps
they then show a statement from this guy
josh zapps of uh he's an australian
broadcasting uh broadcaster whatever he
says
repurposing outback mining accommodation
into international arrival bungalows is
not the same as running a concentration
camp
literally by definition it is
concentration camps are bad because they
brutalize political prisoners not
because they look ugly in aerial photos
this is what i said about the kathy
newman
now to be fair like i i think we all
know concentration camp evokes a kind of
memory of the future what jeremy was
doing but i used that phrase
specifically
not to imply that australia has been
rounding people up and beating them and
executing them though i do think people
they are being mistreated as we've seen
in some of the videos
but just listen to what he's saying
repurposing outback mining accommodation
into international arrival bungalows
it's more than that they're getting
people from their houses as well it's
not just international now hold on that
video they say hotel quarantine it seems
like that was before they had the camp
set up and they were putting people in
hotels but here's my point on that
canada's doing that still right the
hotel's the hotel yeah so this guy is
look they built camps
they literally built camps to
concentrate people right we were we were
just tired it was a huge conspiracy
theory uh the fema camp thing right that
way that never happened in the west that
would never happen here like it's
literally happening right now well so
here's my point
this guy starts you know tweeting you
know i i love how absolutely pathetic
quillette has become i mean i mean that
somewhat i'm being sarcastic it's it's
sad
there was an event we did i was at
milwaukee and i met claire and i was
excited i'm like that does a great job
it's very rational reasonable it's
anti-authoritarian and now they are
literally dropping to their knees and
gagging on boot
when you have videos
of a guy sneezing in an elevator and
then a manhunt and they find him and
they're dragging away in this full gear
while people cheer for it when you have
a video of a guy being taken from his
house for a hotel quarantine it's not
about whether or not they're actively
putting those people in camps it's about
they've created camps to concentrate
people as they come into the country
they're building more of them the the
brisbane brisbane how you pronounce it
camp isn't expected to be finished until
mid 2022. brisbane brisbane so what does
that mean brizzy brizzy
they do not expect that they do not
expect pandemic to end until sometime
after mid-2022 because i really doubt
they're building a camp to just shut
down immediately or not use it all it's
very likely they will use it like
they're using these camps if they're
already willing to show up to someone's
house and take them away for a
quarantine why wouldn't they eventually
just say well we have these quarantine
facilities they're better than the
hotels it's cheaper for everybody so
we'll just put them in the bungalows
it's just a bungalow what's the biggest
yeah you're gonna get pushback that
they're not camps you'll probably start
their cabins concentration cabins well
no no the point is campgrounds have
cabinets oh you're right yeah this is
all this is all political messaging
though how quickly did the phrase kids
in cages switch to whatever the obama or
the bite administration uh were calling
them and and the the circumstances were
far worse by the way i don't know if
you've seen i'm sure you have you've
seen these pictures right of the kids
under the bridge of of kids rolled up in
in thermal blankets it was bad when it
was under trump but at least trump was
actively saying we gotta end this this
which by the way is the same thing that
hillary clinton was saying as secretary
of state in 2013 exactly that right not
come here and and and and bernie yeah
but let's let's throw back to australia
and make this point
in the united states we saw black lives
matter marching through the streets
shoulder to shoulder no masks and the
media said it was fine they're not super
spread our offense because we say so
sturd just happened motorcycle rally not
even overtly political for the most i'm
sure there was politics there but for
the most part it's a motorcycle rally
super spreader event protesters on the
state capital grand stairs super
spreader event we get it obama can have
his big birthday party and everything's
fine even though people did get sick
black lives matter can protest and it's
fine what do you think is going to
happen in australia with these people
protesting the quarantines how long
until the police say well this
quarantine was a super spreader event so
we're going to start putting these
people in quarantine for their own
safety you're developing a mechanism for
them to get retribution against people
politically
and so this guy tweeted at me and said
when that starts happening i'll admit i
was wrong and i'm like and therein lies
my point that you would let it happen
before you would do anything about it
and i would say hey don't let them do it
quillette your cowards
first they came for the uh
socialists and i wasn't a socialist so i
didn't say anything then they came for
the trade union so that wasn't a trade
units and didn't say anything so then
they came for the jews i wasn't a jew so
i didn't see anything and then they came
from me and there was no one left to say
anything that's a very good poem yep man
it's
and by the way even the data she's
talking about is nonsense she's look at
our numbers it's it's we're we're lower
than if we had lost as many the
percentage the united states did do you
know how many cut there's so many
countries sweden uh
forget about sweden uh panama lithuania
nepal libya botswana ireland switzerland
georgia nigeria the republic of the
congo have lower case mortality rates
than australia to be kidding me to be
fair i'm sure that the people of
australia have never heard of benjamin
franklin oh yeah and you know he was
human
we were fortunate enough to have
benjamin franklin who said those that
would sacrifice some uh sacrifice
freedom first for temporary security
deserve neither and will lose
that is covert wrecking like third world
i don't like using that word third world
countries
less industrially developed is covered
wrecking them or is this an obesity
crisis like in the first world there's
two points to be made on third world
countries or underdeveloped nations one
um
there's there's not much data at all
saying that there's large numbers of
deaths and if you look at a lot of the
the the charts and everything you'll see
nothing happening the second point is
they don't have the infrastructure for
tracking a lot of this stuff so
countries with underdevelopment medical
infrastructure aren't tracking i would
also say some of the more i mean once
once the the first wave rolled through
there there's no guarantee that uh adult
development would pop up independently
in that place and how many people are
traveling to third-world countries you
know what i mean right so
less travel
less population density means less
spread which probably mean they reached
uh the fact that they have less access
that they're more crowded together and
have like less access to modern medicine
probably means they reached a higher
percentage of natural immunity faster
than any other place right you would
think so even when even necessity even
when even when a new variant popped up
they would be more protected i mean
everybody knows at this point that the
covered vaccine treats the spike protein
right primarily
right it's it triggers an immune
response to the spike protein right so
but there's there's 28 other proteins on
the covet cell right so if you
i'm telling you that that red circle
with all the stuff coming off it that
you've seen in the news and stuff those
are all little proteins right the spike
protein is the one that's being treated
because that's the one that was causing
us issues the other 28 are not are they
treated to some degree by this because
of the triggered response but nowhere
near as effective as natural immunity
and we see this in this israeli study
it's eight hundred thousand people yeah
you don't get much bigger than that when
it comes to a medical just as the human
brain is greater than any computer we've
ever built i imagine our immune system
is stronger than any medicine we could
ever administer i would imagine i don't
know but i mean the most incredible the
most biomechanical the most protected
you could be is to have had coveted
survived it and also been vaccinated
right yes right thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time